Speaker 1: Republican Congresswoman Liz Cheney
has sort of had enough with some of her Republican
colleagues. She's saying to them, hey, we've
just got to denounce this white supremacy.
We've got to denounce this great replacement
theory stuff. We need to actually forcefully,
not in a mealy mouth and equivocating
way. We just need to denounce the stuff
that has been coming from our side that is in
the Buffalo Shooter's manifesto. And this makes
her slightly less crazy than other Republicans,
but it doesn't make her a political ally. That's
an important thing to remember. So let's talk
this through. Liz Cheney has reportedly said now
that Republican House leaders need to renounce
the insanity that is sort of tied up with what the
Buffalo shooter said. Liz Cheney echoed
a growing chorus that Saturday's race
targeted massacre in Buffalo, New York, was
a product of rhetoric pushed by Republican
leaders. Let's look at the tweet that she sent
where she said The House Republican leadership
has enabled white nationalism, white supremacy
and anti-Semitism. That's correct. Liz Cheney
is right. She went on to say, History has taught
us that what begins with words ends in far worse.
And of course, that's what we saw in Buffalo over
the weekend. Going on to say Republican leaders
must renounce and reject these views and those who
hold them. It's not enough just to say that you're
against violence and that you're against what the
shooter did and that you're against targeting of
black people the way the shooter did. You can't
just kind of pick around the edges at the issue.
Liz Cheney is accurately saying we have to
forcefully say there is simply no place for white
nationalism, white supremacy and anti-Semitism
in the Republican Party. That's what undergirds
the manifesto and the shooting that took place in
Buffalo over the weekend. And Republican leaders,
at least so far, have not been willing to say
that. Now, I think it's important when we talk
about Liz Cheney in these terms to remind you
how low the bar is. Liz Cheney is a complete and
total Trumpist by policy. Well, well, hold on.
What do you mean, David? Well, if you look at
Fivethirtyeight's tracking of Liz Cheney, they
found that in her career, Liz Cheney voted 93%
with Donald Trump's position. Okay. 93% with
Donald Trump's position. During the 115th
Congress, it was 96%. During the 116th Congress,
it was, you know, 92.8%. She almost always is
aligned with Trump or was when Donald Trump
was president. So this is not a political ally.
Sometimes they say these are not our friends. And
some people get mad and they write in and say,
David, that's divisive language. We can all be
friends. Maybe, okay, maybe we can be friends.
Maybe not. Let's just forget about that. These are
not political allies. Yes. Liz Cheney said Trump
was responsible for inciting the insurrection.
Okay. That doesn't make her a political ally. That
just means she's marginally willing to tell the
truth about obvious things. Liz Cheney has said
Donald Trump really lost the election. It wasn't
stolen by Joe Biden. Trump just lost. That's it.
It doesn't make her a political ally. 93% of the
time she still voted with Donald Trump during her
career. And at the end of the day, that's really
how we evaluate someone's political perspective.
So she's absolutely right. She's correctly
pointing out that the Republican leadership
has been mealy mouth and unwilling to sort of
in a full throated way, just denounce the way
that this radical ideology has pervaded the
Republican Party and right wing media. She's
completely correct. But she still voted the way
Trump did. Trump in line with Trump's positions.
93% of the time. So it's just a reminder.
What do we do with that information? Okay.
It's a reminder that as we think about who do we
need in power to achieve change, it's not going to
be slightly less wacky Republicans like Liz
Cheney. That's not where the future of the
left in the United States is. It's not going to
be we can't count on her. It's also not going to
be center right. Democrats like Joe Manchin. We
just have to be realistic about that. That's the
point I'm trying to make here. And Liz Cheney,
good for her. But see if the Republican Party
listens to her. They don't seem to care about what
she has to say. And let's see if they actually
come out in a full throated way, denounce this
ideology that is all over the Buffalo shooting